foreign
let me ask you I have a very personal
question and something that I haven't
shared before that I'd like to ask you
about buying things
oh boy wow no I just I just think that
this is something that that no nobody
talks about and I always like to like
you're so good at at finding stuff that
you know you can pick up in in you're a
very open person which I've always
appreciated about your podcast and like
just like how you
transparent about feelings and emotions
and a lot of things that I think a lot
of men could use to look up to you know
in terms of oh God is this question
gonna be a [ __ ] hydrogen bomb this is
a tough one no no no so here here's
here's a problem that I've had just
being completely honest yeah there was
back when I was in my you know 20s and
early 30s dig was doing quite well
of which is my startup for those of you
don't know was early social News website
that was it was killing it was we had 38
million people a month that we were
visiting the site huge back then it was
one of the top sites on the internet it
was crazy
it started to go sideways and it started
to go down and like not you know like we
were losing to Reddit right it was
starting to kick our ass in some certain
ways and you know we had had dominated
them for many years and then all of a
sudden that was not the case and we were
kind of reeling a little bit
I had sold a tiny bit of my stock
enough to be able to afford an apartment
in in actually buy and put a down
payment on apartment and that's how I
got my page Street Place in NSF and I
remember thinking to myself like I need
to buy myself something it's like it was
a search to feel better right yep and so
I went out and I actually bought and
this is gonna sound super douchey but
I'm okay to say this today like I bought
actually I bought a Porsche I bought a
Porsche 911 back in the day and
looking back on that I realized I was
just in a really difficult sad state
it was it was hard for me you know to
watch this baby of mine and I didn't
know how to course correct it right I
was just so immature in a bunch of
different ways but I was buying for the
sake of trying to fill a gap right don't
get me wrong like I still think vintage
Porsches and old Porsches and Porsches
in general there's beautiful cars like I
I think they're great
I don't I don't have a 911 today but I
will say that
I've noticed the same thing Kevin is not
anti-portion as group text messaging
please don't cancel me Porsche I would
love to be sponsored if you sponsor me
I'm happy to drive 911. so that said you
know here's the crazy thing I went and
ran hodinki the luxury watch brand
company I was CEO there for a few years
and loved my experience there because we
were covering
mechanical like a dying art like it was
like mechanical timepieces and it was
very beautiful in its purest form in
this purest form you talk to an artisan
that is a single independent watchmaker
that takes a year and a half to build
something from scratch and sells 10 a
year that's beautiful like that's that's
those those days are going away and it's
douchey form you're talking to Lambo
drivers that just want to have a flex
that they can hold a watch on their
wrist that says I have five million
dollars on my wrist right like that's a
real thing and so
I met with Allah as his CEO of this
company this is like the you know the it
still is the the largest watch brand
editorial site in the world and
you would meet all these collectors and
they would come up to you and they come
in all different shapes and sizes and it
was clear to me that some of these dudes
like blessed them they were trying to
fill that same thing that I was trying
to fill where you got me spend money on
something to make yourself feel
in a group you'll connect to feel
connection because you'd come out and
you'd say these are other collectors
like me like I you know it's tough and
and I'm not anti-watch I still I
remember wearing an Apple Watch today
but I I still have a few timepieces that
were really meaningful to me including
one that my dad left me when he passed
away
and and I and I still love that that
whole thing but how do you approach this
as somebody have you ever
spent your money on things and then how
do you approach it with
like have you ever done that and then
also how do you approach that with with
significant others like you know I've
had this conversation with my wife about
like hey we don't have to wear the
flashy stuff it's okay to wear you know
I told her the other night like one of
my my favorite times to hang out with
you is when it's jeans and t-shirts like
version of you at a bar like I love that
yeah having a beer like we don't have to
be fancy la like I don't want that like
where do you stand on on all this stuff
so I think
and and you've probably observed this in
me you're so good at this this is why
I'm trying to pick your brain you don't
do any flashy [ __ ] well I'm good but
there is a
downside
there is a trade-off and I have not
figured out how to contend with this and
I'll actually mention also a book
that has come up several times in the
last week from multiple people
I respect and
remember Rick Rubin the the music
producer said to me when that happens to
him he feels like it's a
signal from the universe that he needs
to take a look at something and so I
kind of feel like that right now with
this book which I'll come to in a second
I
have had
very few instances of buying expensive
things for myself
and you've seen this oh I know I I don't
think I don't think I'm
stingy in all things
for instance I will go to if I think the
experience is going to leave an
indelible Mark in my mind
I will go to a place like alinea in
Chicago and have a meal and I did that
and I'm really glad I did and it's very
expensive right I mean I would consider
it very expensive it's like fifteen
hundred two thousand bucks for a meal
and that on some level would make the
15 year old version of me going to a
seizure right like did not grow up with
a lot of money
and grew up in a household where
scarcity of money was an issue and my
dad would yell at my mom for spending
too much money on stuff because we she
we literally bounce checks like I
remember that being a conversation like
the account is overdrawn like yeah yeah
it was a source of stress it was a
source of stress and so I decided pretty
early on
as a kid okay
I do not want this type of stress in my
life that means I need to figure out how
to make money
and that in a way was the spark behind
my entrepreneurial
experiments it's like okay this this
type of stress that I have been immersed
in and exposed to
and I don't think it traumatized me I
wouldn't put it that way I wouldn't uh I
wouldn't want to remove the power of
that word trauma by applying it to
something like this and I think it kind
of disgusts me how overused the word
trauma is
that's a separate thing but
it affected me definitely imprinted
something on me and
as a result
I have spent relatively little money
celebrating anything right the fact that
I spent like these Japanese Saddles
right I bought them at auction from an
OP from I can't remember it was
Christie's or Sotheby's
and I think it was
five thousand dollars a piece right and
and to to allow myself to do that
the hurdle was not only do I have to
finish and publish a book that is 500
plus pages I think there's maybe 700
Pages which was cut down from probably
1500 pages was this in your head or did
some Euro down
like this is a hurdle that you had to
like you're like it was in my head but I
I said if if I publish this book and it
is number one New York Times I will
allow myself
as a reward to buy these Saddles that
cost five thousand dollars each and if I
don't
I'm not allowed to do this
so on some level I respect that and it's
very
strict high standards and on some level
all of those things are good but
what I will say is
when I meet
or spend time with friends of mine
who have achieved some degree of success
and it it's it's not always millions of
dollars right they've they've just
figured out
a job and a seal where they've developed
a career and they're stable and they fix
a lot of problems for themselves and
they add a lot of joy for themselves and
their families by spending money
the dark side of what I'm describing is
that I don't think I've developed that
very well and so I have and I have more
money than I know what to do with and I
think I put I put it I don't want to
sound like a prick that doesn't mean
that I'm just like doing
backstroke through a pool full of gold
coins like Scrooge McDuck that's not
what I'm saying I put I think I am a
very very
hopefully this doesn't sound pompous I I
think I'm a very very good
capital allocator and Steward of money I
think I use
what I have to very high Leverage
means and and and
objectives through funding the science
and the journalism fellowship with
Michael Pollan and so on like but but
here's what I'll say Kevin is is
there's there's a dark side to it in
that I I don't use money to fix problems
that I should fix
like what give me an example
you know I'll give an example which
would be
there are little things I'll give you a
perfect example so
there is an article it's not really an
article it's more an adaptation of
John Stuart Mill's ideas on Free Speech
which is an Illustrated Edition it's
called all minus one you can find it on
Amazon you can also get it for free I
think it's at
heterodoxacademy.org Mill
and this came about
through a conversation with Jonathan
height who is fascinating thinker and
professor and researcher who wrote the
coddling of the American mind and many
other books
so this is let's see on Kindle it's
I think 78 pages
and
I agonized over when I was going to find
time to print this and
put it together in a hard copy so that I
could mark it up because I didn't want
to wait for the paperback
I have employees I could send this to
someone and just be like hey figure this
out whatever makes it readable go right
it would take it 30 seconds but there's
part of me for whatever reason that gets
stuck on doing it myself and doesn't
even consider that it doesn't enter my
head as an option
and there are many other examples of
this right I've been to friends houses
where
they love let's not name names but
because you'll probably get it but like
but I have I have a friend who really
loves topachico and you go to his house
and he always has a refrigerated drawer
full of Topo Chico yeah it's never empty
he never runs out it's extra sparkly
it's good it is yeah it'll definitely
take all the enamel off your teeth it's
delicious and
and even though all the Hipster Austin
Knights have boycotted it because it's
owned by the evil empire of colonos and
they're you know they're drinking uh
Richard's rainwater and and others which
are fine fine fine sparkling water but I
just I just find the outrage pretty
hilarious
but the point is like he has
a team he pays people to help
him and his family with their lives in
various ways so that he can focus on
things he's really good at which does
not include
figuring out at the last minute oh [ __ ]
I'm out of Topo Chico how am I gonna
make it in time to the grocery store to
buy this and chew up 45 minutes of my
time
I don't have many of those systems in
place and it's not because I am
consciously deciding I need to save
money it's like the option doesn't even
appear
on my mental
UI to choose so this is something I'm
trying to figure out which leads to the
book
which has been recommended number of
times now which is called die with zero
have you I've not read it I've heard
about this actually so full disclosure
I've not Chris Hutchin sent this to me
oh no [ __ ] okay so Bill Perkins
is the author and I should know better
than to recommend something
before I've read it so I just want to
make it super clear I have not read this
but the book is
die with zero getting all you can from
your money and your life and it's
written by Bill Perkins who's a famous
energy Trader slash investor
and the
Wall Street Journal bestseller I'll just
read a little bit of the description
which is very
seductive to me because it's written by
someone who has also been an operator
book were written by just someone who's
waxing poetic without any real Bona
fides bonafides I would be skeptical but
this is someone who's actually been a
real operator in the trenches so the
description is a common sense guide To
Living Rich instead of dying Rich
imagine if by the time you died you did
everything you were told to you worked
hard saved your money and looked forward
to Financial Freedom when you retired
the only thing you wasted along the way
was dot dot dot your life
die with zero presents a startling new
and provocative philosophy as well as
practical guide and how to get the most
out of your money and the most out of
your life it's intended for those who
place lifelong memorable experiences far
ahead of Simply making and accumulating
money for one so-called golden years and
it goes on yes
this is interesting to me and I'm I'm
hoping that it provides me with some
counter programming that will maybe help
me to do more and I have I will say
been finding some Outlets where I don't
have Hang-Ups and one is spending money
on art or supporting artists so I'll be
I will be doing moving forward
quite a few experiments with artists and
artwork